so please just to start off here for a
second Pedro please introduce yourself
to the hot breath the first let him know
a little bit about you and your your
comedy background sure so I'm originally
from Colombia and I came to United
States about 16 years ago
and about six and a half years ago I was
living in Philly and I was watching this
webcam series about comedy called modern
comedian I think yeah it's a great show
yeah and they had an episode on open
mikes and then they profiled Suva Hager
wall who was doing like 20 months a week
and I was like in my first month of
comedy and I realized well I mean I'm
like two hours away from New York and if
I can do so if I can get on stage so
much why not just go to New York and I
came and I started doing mics like a
maniac and never stopped until the
corner of I restarted but like a maniac
how many shows are we talking about a
night a week
I don't know that shows like for the
first two years there was no show I just
I have I don't know if you can see as I
have a calendar do you see yeah very
cool it's empty right now for March
because I do you remember that this
Seinfield technique like every day that
he rode he would have a calendar and
every night here every day he wrote he
would put an X on the day so I at the
end of the month he would have a visual
for how many days a month he wrote yeah
he called it breaking the chain correct
yes I use the same technique but just
for performing so so like every day that
I did a two mics or three mics I would
write two then at the end of the week I
would add it up and then I'd be in at
the month I would know that I would do
that I had done let's say 45 mics a
month or 60 Mike's a month and for my
first two years I basically didn't have
any shows huh it just makes myk's myk's
myk's
yeah that's yeah I mean um yeah and
definitely not even everything booked
but like open mics you're saying you're
do
like 45 to 60 a month is what you were
saying it's not 70 yeah in my first and
second year jeez Louise and do you have
a day job during this time or what is
what's that hustle always had a day job
uh-huh so it was it was kind of like if
you date Joe I would have a day job that
started like any 8:30 so then I would
wake up but I would like write every
morning from 6:00 from 7:00 to 8:00 just
like just like a little hour at least
and then after work I would go and do a
Mike at 5 at 6:00
and at 7 and then be little by 8 or done
by 9 and what is uh what what is the day
job do you still have your day job by
the way I yes Wow okay so what are you
you can you say what your day job is
sure sure sure
I am I mean I mean I'm an interpreter at
a legal aid firm okay
very cool yeah yes so you never know
when like when you see people on TV you
never know what oh and he's drinking out
of his Colbert a mug by the way he
pointed that out on look I perlier yes
so I am I'm drinking out of the hot
breath water as well so we're adding on
brand here so yeah people feel free
Trent like to don't break the chain idea
and Athena liked the idea as well so
that's great and kids feel free jump in
in the comments with any questions but I
would like to get into a little bit more
of Pedro and it sounds like and what's
funny is the guy that produces produced
that show modern comedian Scott Moran
actually did a show with him in Atlanta
several years ago and he was showing me
like the the early early he had he was
started posting him yet cuz he's done
someone like Rory Scovel who he's now
directed some of Roy's scovilles comedy
specials and he directed a Todd Glass's
comedy special as well so he's actually
like a director in comedy now but he was
showing me like the early behind the
scenes of him cutting
together that show in the green mom and
it's cool to just see the views it's
gotten and the impact cuz I saw that
Suba episode and it really inspired me
to really get on my hustle so I
recommend yeah any comics listening to
this go check out that series there's a
really good one about Mitch Hedberg as
well that really shows him and and his
creative process like never before
mmm so in terms of I'm interested in the
late-night part now people you can ask
questions anything about his writing or
anything cuz it sounds like he's he has
a good writing system but first off like
how did you even book Colbert so my I
got recommended by two people who did it
uh-huh and I didn't they just they did
it without me asking interested yeah
so the Booker for Colbert she's she's
super busy she's like she's always in LA
or and you you know it's really hard to
catch her because she's got a lot of
things going on um she asked for my
schedule I'm talking about like a year
ago it was the first time that she said
tell me your show schedule and I went to
I was doing this festival in Boston
called women and Comedy Festival
I was doing the guest set there and she
was like she was supposed to come to
that show but then she couldn't make it
and then I didn't know the festival
called the West Side comedy show down in
Los Angeles and she was she was supposed
to be a judge of the contest and I was
opening the show and before I did my set
she got a phone call and she left so so
it was so the whole thing about her
seeing me live it was not as easy it was
it wasn't easy even though I had already
recommended and she wanted and she had
expressed interest but she just had so
many other commitments that we just
didn't get to the same place at the you
know the happy Clinton never
happened and the second time she sent me
an email and she said send me you latest
500k my intuition is that that like I
don't think I was busy with something
else but at the moment I didn't think I
thought maybe I'm gonna close this deal
when she sees me live so I sort of like
didn't really pay attention to this I
did to this request and then I emailed
back and I was like can I send it in a
couple of weeks cuz I just don't have
that many great shows coming up and she
was like I need it by Friday because I
have a stand-up meeting and so then I
just asked for a bunch of spots which I
usually don't do and got the tape send
the tape forgot about it two weeks later
I got an email saying greenlight you're
doing it what yeah so wonder and I think
there's a little bit of a clicking or
something are you are you tapping the
table or anything I might be but I will
stop no I don't know I just started some
someone's gonna say if no one else is
doing don't worry about it but I just
kept hearing kind of something as you
were talking but okay is it gun now
so far okay
I've just been doing this podcast long
enough to know anyone will find a reason
to to like complain about the audio or
something if they get a chance I get it
can you make your guests talk closer to
the mic and I was like hey I'm doing
everything I can here alright I'm sorry
God but yeah I just wanted to do uh so
let's let's get focused here so I wonder
what was so it's kind of like you went
it took about a year it says a year ago
she's like show me her schedule and then
it's like Oh she'll get to see me live
and they know she did in and then to me
the new clip and then how long between
[Music]
her saying yes to the new being on the
show like what was that what was that
turn around I think it was about six
weeks six weeks turn around okay cool
six weeks turnaround
Wow yes an entire process even being
recommended by two other comics mm-hmm
and this speaking of recommendations I
like this one
Z says Pedro are you going to refer Joel
buyers just an idea
just an idea just an idea
you know I think I can't see the
comments so I can't tell that the guy is
real but I think I think bringing up the
whole thing is the recommendation thing
it's it's a good thing to keep in mind
and I don't know what other people's
focuses on that are but it's like when I
think that when it comes to comedy when
somebody wants to recommend you for
something they can't wait to do it so so
it's like it's like if you're a very
attractive person somebody's gonna ask
you to prom
yeah and you go like you know what I if
I can proactive and I ask all these
people to prom then then it's gonna
happen but it's I don't know I don't
want to make it about looks but they
know what what would you know what I'm
trying to say I'm not pretty enough for
TV is that way no you say there was a
problem like everything like at least
that's my philosophy when I'm I rarely
asked to get booked right I worked hard
enough and I never think about getting
any and like getting booked or getting
recommended for this to that and I and I
just let my work speak for itself
yes I love that and I think that's such
an important point that it took me years
into comedy to realize of just focus on
what you can control
don't have expectations of other people
really just focus on just getting as
funny as possible and instead of trying
to white-knuckle myself and force myself
in an opportunity when I just took a
step back and was just like what am i
control of I'm in control of getting on
stage as much as possible I'm in control
of writing and then letting all the
Opera
two knees come from that and it's
actually become my greatest success has
come from just focusing on me and
getting as good at comedy as possible
and everything kind of bloomed from that
and it seems like with you you didn't
ask for these recommendations you just
got recommended by two previous
performers and then boomed yeah let work
speak for itself I loved it and you were
on there with Larry David by the way did
you get to meet him or anything oh my
god I wish well here's a here's a little
nugget about Colbert Colbert is uh they
taped the stand-up showcase separately
they chopped it up and then they plug it
whenever so my like Stephen wasn't there
when I taped oh okay gotcha which
probably makes it a little less
nerve-wracking
you know yeah that wasn't like I wasn't
I was a little nervous but I wasn't
super nervous gotcha I'm like when
people talk about their Letterman
there's such like I was about to die
that day and it was like but then so
then I was thinking why wasn't it like
that and I was like oh of course cuz I
wasn't performing I've never nervous I'm
never nervous about the audience I'm
nervous about the comedians in the back
who's got well luckily you're funny and
thank you how long have you been doing
comedy by the way uh about six and a
half years six and a half years that's
great awesome yeah I um actually went
through a phase where I was like oh let
me uh I want to get on Conan and then I
was like oh I want to get on Colbert and
then I was like no I just want to be
really funny like I was kind of I had
all these vanity goals that I wasn't in
control of so it's it's it think it's
reassuring for comedians to see someone
at your experience level but also your
mindset so young into comedy of I just
let the work speak for itself I think
that's I mean that that speaks volumes
that I think comedians can already just
take that nugget
let your
speak for itself so that being said and
thinking of the work Carly said I want
to know more about the writing routine
so I think just just to kind of
piggyback that I would be interested to
know you mentioned having a daily
writing discipline you would be right
before work and then also maybe
translate that also into how you
prepared for the Colbert set as well so
maybe starting off with how you created
your routine what is your routine what
is your writing and then how it parlays
into Colbert sure I think the writing I
just made it automatic like just wake up
take a shower to make a cup of coffee
piece of toast open the notebook don't
think and just start right I never have
anything prepared and I think that when
when I was doing
I still do Mike sometimes but when I was
doing Mike's like on my second year I
had I had a friend who was like well
just it's it's hard for me to get
motivated to write and and then you've
had him write then it then it's uh for
me to go on stage because I don't have
anything new right I mean my point was
like yeah so you know what your problem
is the moment you have something new to
try you can't wait to go on stage hmm so
it's so it's it's either a vicious cycle
or a virtuous cycle so I guess the the
reason I've been so hungry to perform so
much is because I write every day for
about 60 to 80 minutes in the morning
before I go to my day job that's 60 80
minutes and that's how I am too though
if I don't write I don't feel inspired
to perform cuz there is like there's
nothing new to try or you know yeah so
it's it's not like you've create a
routine around it so it is like you had
to make it something you didn't think
about where it is like okay I write up a
shower coffee writing that's almost like
the regimen every day you just had to
instill yeah of course because if you
think about it when you're writing a
stand-up you're digging into your
childhood your insecurities and and then
and then a joke is like
there's perfect little line that almost
doesn't make sense
Samantha it's like it's something off
the wall something that surprises people
makes them laugh it's something that you
would never expect it and for you to be
able to come up with that you at least
in my case I just need a lot of a lot of
like I don't want to say free writing
but just a lot of experience of putting
thing down some paper and reworking them
until I find the way until I find the
right way of expressing something the
best way of expressing something yeah
what is that
I did mention nothing is prepared either
so you kind of take the pressure off of
having to create lightning in a bottle
every time you sit down
I am I'm a big fan of and that's why I
do the right 10 Club every morning is
because it's like just show up and just
write like even just for 10 minutes a
lot of the time 10 minutes will grow
into 20 30 60 but it's like you just
have to start and take away all the
pressure and expectation so with with
you is it free riding is it you're just
kind of journaling about the day or do
you have prompter
I actually I have I have a little
notebook that I wanted to show you with
like that so basically I don't know if
you can see this you can see this page
okay yeah if they if I had gotten
anything that I would think it's worth
talking about I would have like put a
little bracket and then and then I would
take my little notebook and I write two
words that will remind me to go and try
it on the stage
right okay sometimes I can go like if
you go through my notebook there could
be like say seven days where there is
nothing right I came up with nothing
right but you know why I just feel at
the end of the day I just feel great I'm
like oh I woke up when I wrote and
nothing came out but I put I'm
exercising my brain like I am
fine tuning mic my writing comedic voice
and it's fine
so I think the moment that I taught
myself to take of the pressure that's
when I became freed or like become funny
okay yeah that makes any sense yeah take
off the pressure of writing because a
lot of times we try to force it and we
squeeze it so tight they wind up
suffocating it as opposed to just
letting it be what it is right right so
I have I found a day where I came up
with a bit like if you want me to I'll
give you like a little breakdown of how
I came up with the bit
absolutely please okay so on March 14th
the day I woke up and I I did have
normally I don't have anything that I'm
gonna write about I'll just put them
like oh I had I had a cup of coffee I
bought coffee above Allah this day I
decided to talk about when I didn't have
health insurance and I lost a tooth
right it's embarrassed like when
something is embarrassing or scary or
like it makes you uncomfortable or it's
humiliating
of course that's good for humor so so I
do I have this little I try something
for like for like five four or five
lines mm-hmm different approach and the
same thing does that make sense uh you
actually cut out right when you said
that can you say that again sure sure
sure I if you see this little this
little bullet point mm-hmm there's a
little bull and I'll do something for
like four or five lines to see if I find
a funny approach and if I don't I drop
it and I and I start again gotcha
okay so once you find something that
strikes you you try to explore that a
little bit more by asking questions or
so so for example in this one highroad
that i was talking about the fact that i
have two dental implants and then i took
the approach of like so as a person who
hasn't had the dental care I should I
believe that everyone should have free
dental care right and then I did a
little try to
[ __ ] joke about healthcare nothing
nothing panned out gotcha
and and okay what's what's dating like
without a tooth
so then drew I would I try to make in
and out like analogy oh go on a day
without with a missing tooth is like
auditioning for Julia without keyboard
on your piano rape still not funny okay
dating part didn't work then at then I
had it then I was like okay what else
can I compare it with and in its I rode
the next one is a missing arm is a sign
of an accident a missing tooth is a sign
of your parents had you as an accident
yeah I'd like when I ready today I was
like this isn't even bad I'm not sure
like right now when I put a little
bracket and maybe I'll tweet it or I'll
try turning state but that wasn't the
day so then I kept going and I said and
this isn't even funny but it's like the
reason people don't judge you when you
lose an arm is because you had a it was
unfortunate that something bad happened
to you well as when you lost your tooth
it's like that was you choice to not
brush your [ __ ] teeth right then
that's right again didn't come to um
didn't come to any jokes then I said
it's embarrassing to go and and then I
just started brainstorming like what
would be a job interview on the phone if
you're like if you don't have teeth and
you found like that maybe they give you
a job because they think you're mentally
this was the term disabled you have
mental dis right so then that led me to
go oh what if I actually went in a real
interview for it to be and then was it
what's the worst place to get rejected
from Walmart right role Walmart will
hire anybody
so then I so then I came up with the
idea that I was interviewing for to be a
greeter at Walmart and then the guy was
like good interview but I can't have you
smiling in I can't have you greeting
customers with that that doesn't look
nice because you're missing teeth
you missing a tooth and then I got like
my comb back would be like but that guy
I like I look at the greeter and I look
like that guy is missing a chromosome
and then the guy comes back and he's
like well but he looks adorable when he
smiles that's that's a joke that's in
progress but I but I I came to it going
like all the way and exploring all this
different of those different things so I
don't know if that helps to to like oh
yeah that totally helps and it seems
like you find something you in that
strikes you as interesting or funny and
you put it in brackets and then you may
explore it with different questions and
different situations that that idea may
create humor out of right yeah and this
this actually is kind of piggybacks into
the next question but Z asks when you
write so much how do you decide what to
keep slash try I guess
when you hit something that is like that
that feels like a joke I think that's
when you have to like trust your
intuition yes feel yeah most of it is
just garbage right which i think is
important for comedians to hear is that
I mean in any level you know I've
interviewed comedians 20 years into this
and they'll say one out of every 20
things they end up keeping so I it's
good for younger comics to hear that
most of what you write is just nonsense
or it is garbage and it's not going to
work I think a good lesson for me was I
went to a UCB show and I show louis c.k
ones and he was doing this bit about the
idea of pavements what if somebody's
laying payment and then the the
construction guys watched false and then
he puts on the payment and then he wants
to retrieve the thing he has to Borrego
and then he go he just looks at his book
and he's thick this is a stupidest thing
I've ever
how would he ever think this was funny
and then I was like oh well if somebody
who's been doing it for 25 years or 30
years can fail allow him something to
fail
why shouldn't I fail exam that's that's
I think I think sometimes we look at
them and we're like they're geniuses but
not it they're not necessarily geniuses
but they're people who like really work
hard at their craft yeah and that that's
so that's a very big benefit to doing
comedy New York is you do get to see all
of these just titans of comedy failing
on stage oh yeah
are there any are there any other
memories of seeing someone like at a
louis c.k level getting to see them live
working out stuff I mean I've seen mark
Normand I think he is that I'd like
really respect the most and I've just I
saw him once I think it was like a
Monday and I saw him at UCB at 11:20
mm-hmm like after 11:00 p.m. but he was
he was doing a 20-minute set or
something 15 minutes I and I remember
seeing him at 5 p.m. at an open mic at a
stand of New York with three people and
I remember thinking if I was if I had a
20-minute set at midnight god that's
good enough for me to work anything out
however this guy who's like killing it
already is so committed to working that
he's trying it out at an open mic at
5:00 p.m.
and I thought he was great yeah he's
right and he had some and he had a
couple bits that just didn't go anywhere
and he was and he was like embarrassed
and I was like oh look it's okay to make
mistakes
it is that's how you learn yeah he our
first interview we did with them he at
the time I don't know if he still holds
it but at the time he held the record
for doing the most open mics in a year
in New York because he's constantly on
stage right right
Oh a good uh Ramiro says the breakdown
about the tooth joke was super helpful
so that's good well great this and this
sucks but the breakdown was good
it was very cyfle I haven't really heard
someone kind of breakdown their process
like that before so that's that's why
we're doing this cool
so keeping in joke breakdown cuz I I do
want to think about the Colbert thing as
well
and kind of tied in Trevor Glassman here
he asked how long did it take for you to
shape and perfect that set you did on
Colbert and also and how did you go
about choosing what jokes to do slash
shape I think it just I think he came
out like I think it shaped itself
organically I remember the first sign
that I did there very New York has less
industry than you think
so I was I was just focusing on my
writing my jokes but and there's few
occasions when you go on you showcase
for industry like laughing skull like
the festival in Atlanta right so I did
that like three years ago or four years
ago so I was like two and a half years
into comedy so there I am with my five
minutes and I have two and a half that
are clean and are about me about my
family about where I'm from and they're
funny and they're clean and then I have
my my like oh I'm three years into
comedy and they have this cancer bit let
me let me just throw it in and then it's
like you know it's like that's not what
they want for does not what they want
for TV but so I kept I kept writing and
it just I think he organically came to
be something about like oh this is
something about I was made fun of my
looks for this this is something that I
observed that is different from my
culture to American culture this is
something that happened to me in dating
this is a racist thing that a guy told
me at an airport and this is my
experience dating I'm like I'm not
giving you a formula but I'm saying like
six things that were like they were all
about me well and and they were and they
were and they were clean I think I think
sometimes people go like oh I don't want
to do that
I don't want to plate them or whatever
but it's like a certain point you should
know who you're trying to perform for
and then again as I told you I wasn't
writing for them
I don't think Lena TV is the ultimate
goal I was just writing what I thought
was funny
I need happened to be very personal yeah
it was very Anna right and as far as
like selecting so once so I've never
asked for spots but once I was told
you're doing colbert then I just hit up
everybody with the because like that
emails it's a little easier to get
responded to when it's like Oh preparing
for Colbert people are like yeah come do
my show and one thing that I that I did
is every show that I did I would have
the host the host always ask you what do
you want as an introduction and I was
like please say that I'm that I'm doing
this and Colbert because that makes the
audience go like oh let me see if this
is funny
mm-hmm so that makes me nervous so the
day when I'm taping Colbert I I've been
as nervous as I'm ever gonna be does
that make sense so you set the
expectation that oh this is going to be
something special so you almost have to
rise to the occasion for the audience
yeah yeah for the audience if they're
there they're expecting big things so
you gotta better bring it type deal
right but for me I kept and then again
every person everyone's process is
different I kept writing new jokes
because I was like what if I come up
with like my funniest joke ever before
the day before right
right right and I had a friend who had
done it and he was like what are you
doing I keep running to him at Mike's
and I was like look look I'm gonna put
this new joke and he's like when did you
write that joke and I was like yes if
they and he'd be like are you insane
this is your best of the best and I was
like yeah I am the best possible writer
today so so maybe that maybe the best
joke is gonna come and I actually put in
I think two jokes that wearing
my submission tape oh wait did they know
you were gonna do them are you yeah oh
you just showed up the a of and we're
like I'm gonna try these or how did that
go no no no day off so after I got the
green light
i I co incite it with Jessica uh-huh
show in Los Angeles Jessica's the Booker
by the way for anyone listening right
yeah so I just sandwich the jokes in the
set and at the end of the thing she came
and she was like really good job you're
gonna do great and that was all the
feedback and guidance oh that's great
okay
I guess if they didn't have any big
edits I mean that's a good sign cuz I've
heard the opposite where they're like
these four are great but you gotta take
out these three you know type deal so
yeah yeah I am i I also heard that so
the moment that I get the green light I
try to start communicating with him
immediately and I would say I thought I
was like a red pen ready and I was like
tell me what you're gonna cross and then
I'll work around that right right that's
fine and I got booked I want to get it
over with so I'll work with you guys but
I but I I had all the support I think
they trusted me and they just told me
good job go and do it out there great
yeah so when I'm trying to think how
many times do you think you ran that set
before you performed it on TV I can tell
you I can I would say I ran until I was
I was bored okay running it let's say
six weeks six weeks an average of 15
times probably 90 x 90 times okay not
any time and and it was I mean I don't
know
I also know that friends of mine who had
who have done so Jimmy Fallon right
mm-hmm
I was also talking to them my manager
called me on a Friday and he said what
do you have a us for Monday he didn't
tell me for a while and then I didn't
hear anything a Monday and then I found
out that I was this close from being
called to do um found on a Monday and
that Monday so I would have had no sense
of preparation if that in the case right
so I feel like and I've seen friends of
mine who have done it on that but it's
also said that you've been have you been
doing for years and using you so you
sort of know it I think the I think the
reason I prepared so much is because you
never wanna you never want to show up
and [ __ ] up and know that it's because
you you just chose not to great mm-hmm
when you have when you've booked for
that you can get all the bookings you
could ever get to do a bar show to do a
CD show so then why not take advantage
yes I think that's that's a answering
Trevor's second question was like
choosing the jokes it was stuff that was
personal but also clean as well but you
even talking about trying new stuff
Ramiro kind of chimed in here and asking
did you hate any of the jokes and is
that why you were trying to put in new
jokes in took Colbert on mmm no I liked
I maybe the jokes that I took out were
jokes that I wrote like in my second
year and I and I have just told him
enough that I felt the writing on the
new ones was stronger so then I just I
just decided to include those nice very
nice yeah and that is interesting you
mentioned having management and six and
a half years in you know I'm still doing
everything independently but this
trevor actually just chimed in with this
as well but like how far into comedy and
where did you get management and how has
it been vital to your success so I got
management last year 2019 when I went to
Latin skull
oh you did the Laughing Skull Fest last
year yes cool so I so I as I said I did
it three years before and I just went
and I was like AIDS cancer great and
then and then I came back when I had my
voice was like a little more refined
right and I and I did my set and he was
one of those like little movie moments
when I'm in the green room with my with
my comedian friends and one of the
late-night Booker's just be lines to me
and he sits down let's start working on
your tape you're gonna be in like we
want to have you in the show and then my
friends just give me I look over like oh
[ __ ] and then I go to the after-party
and and my manager now approached me and
he was like hey I really enjoy your said
we had like a very friendly
non-committal conversation and then he
was like I'm gonna call you in a couple
weeks if that's okay he called me in a
couple weeks and he he he told me the
company he worked for it's three arts is
a really good company yeah we said um I
didn't know I was like sure I did I told
people hey I'm working with this guy
from tears on the and they were like you
don't know and I was like mmm
they were like have you never watched
the end of a special where they show who
made the special and I was like why it's
it's finished for the jokes for the for
the industry stuff and then he told me
I'm very happy to start working with you
and I just thought when are we gonna get
the paperwork is this guy really like is
he is he not my manager now and it's
like it turns out that many of the big
companies don't make you sign anything
yeah and so I've been working so
laughing this goal is very instrumental
going back to the point of like maybe
it's really good to just figure out
where you can be seen and just go try
I'd say that there's a couple like
really good festivals like limestone
Laughing Skull the West Side comedy
showdown has that's because it's in LA
so it is good industry people coming to
check it out like agents managers and
yeah just I mean try to get out places
and get seen I would say now as far as
working with the manager has been has
been a blessing I think it I already
started the late-night thing on my own
just by being lucky that I got seen by
industry in in random places and so be
besides that when you have a manager
it's like ever since I have my manager I
started he gave me an idea to start
writing a TV show sitcom because I was
working at the DEA before I did before I
did call me so I'm writing is sick I'm
about that and it's just like I think
once you get management they don't
change everything for you like bookings
you need a booking agent right you need
like a an agency that's like okay
there's a agent for acting there's an
agent for touring and there's an agent
for literary well my manager advised me
to do is let's let's take it easy
because there is after I did Colbert one
good thing about Colbert is that people
from William Morris Endeavor saw me and
they were like you want to try William
Morris right yeah I'll be needed me yeah
uh-huh
and then I also did stand-up NBC last
year and some people from CAA saw me and
they're like we're one
we want to talk so then awesome now I
don't have an agent
mm-hmm because I think we're trying to
choose someone that that has the best
rapport and it has offered the best
opportunities but then again they're now
gonna be like oh I'm your agent now go
be a go be a headliner because they have
headliners who have a lot of followers a
lot of tickets they can like you can be
a YouTube celebrity and just go or like
a tick tock celebrity and just go and
talk about your tick-tock and as you
sell out you will be on tour mm-hmm so I
think in terms of like stand-up it
doesn't transform anything it doesn't
make you a headliner
I also haven't tried because I still
have a day job I haven't gone crazy and
like message the whole world to see how
many bookings I can get us a feature or
whatever in terms of like showing you
that the possibilities are endless
it's good to have a manager because like
now that I'm working my manager is like
I'm right now like the day I finished
taping Colbert the day after I was
working on a pilot for a sitcom Wow and
that's through the guidance of your
manager like right put the idea in your
head yeah and I interviewed a Tamra
Goins who is the head of comedy at
innovative artists out in LA so she's
worked with a lot and she was able to
break down the difference between like
management and having an agent and she
said an agent is more transactional
where it's like here's work let me take
my cut but management is more like
you're saying it's more like a
mentorship more like a guidance more
like giving yeah helping your career
long but her advice was before you have
a manager make have something to manage
you know a lot a lot of times people
comics just feel like they're gonna get
that manager and then that's where their
success is going to come it's kind of
like no first have something to bring to
the table that they can help mold into
like a bigger idea but a lot of times
people want management without
even having anything to manage you know
yeah of course
so for example one one good example
about that is just for laughs and how
the only addition the real additions are
only if you have a manager right for
repped right right right and then I've
seen many many cases where people get
wrapped super early and a few cases
where people have been doing comedy for
four years or something age they go to j
FL and j FL you're performing for like a
thousand industry members and they go
besides this five minutes what do you
have and then you go another minute and
they go okay bye so then I never like
whenever I was like oh I'm six years
into comedy five and a half years into
comedy and I'm not wrapped if I've only
hour wrapped my life would be so
different but it's like no I'd rather go
and they'd like I'd rather go maybe this
year or next year when I have a freaking
show to give you hey who wants this show
cuz it's a great show and then people
and then also some people are just like
if only I had a late night TV credit
guess why it doesn't pay you $100,000
you get a lot of friends being like good
job and it's good and it's it's it's a
proof of your of your merits but you got
a thing bigger than that I think yeah
it's it's super important it's just I
think like you said at the beginning man
it really is just like let your work
speak for itself that's really where
your opportunities are gonna be it's not
this one experience that just makes
changes everything it's a gradual
process over time and just like
developing a joke it's gradual over time
so just letting your work speak for
yourself having those tangible things
cuz now it is more important than ever
like comedians do have more than one
thing it's like okay you're funny on
stage
what else can you act do you have a
podcast do you have a pilot it's like
what else do you have besides being
funny on stage of course and this does
this does tie into really two questions
in one
first off Trent says three arts Congrats
cuz that is a big deal I mean it's at
the end of every special it's at the end
of Louis show like three arts is known
as like the gold standard when it comes
to comedy so definitely congrats on that
thank you and this is kind of a
combination but Trent asks and is is
this the next step of your career a
comedy special like do you have 40 plus
minutes of material and that does parlay
into ramiro also asked like what is your
goal now after Colbert you have a
full-time job are you wanting to quit
the job and do stand-up full-time so
it's kind of a two-part or like what's
next for you I think that's a really
good question I was on the verge of
quitting my day job to just like move in
with my girlfriend and just like hit up
everybody go go perfect my my feature
said dude like learn to do like I saw it
30 minutes and and just try to put it
somewhere where people see it and we're
like the I think Netflix right now would
be the only streaming service that is
like worth putting your special on oh
look I'm talking I don't know anything
right but I've listened I mean how many
how many people that you have
interviewed have told you that nobody
saw their Comedy Central
Oh half-hour like all of them right so
like you asked anybody who's done one
and they go like I don't know that it's
I don't know that it's worth it right so
people who are doing the stuff that
you're doing you're building your
audience by putting your thing out there
Samara I don't know he did it with I
don't know who he did it with but he
just put something out a million views
right I get as many YouTube subscribers
as you can like the Andrew Scholes model
yeah so for me if they come I don't know
that I'm wise like like social media
wise like that with them
I would love to keep growing my act to
make money on the road as far as
standard and to get that special perfect
- maybe if be able to sell to like HBO
or Netflix and the sitcom is just like
because I found it like an entertaining
something that I'm passionate about I
read some scripts and I just found them
amazing and it was like I would love to
learn to do that now and that's what I'm
doing now just like I have this like out
of this this is 100 pages and 98 are
just nothing and two of them are like a
few jokes I have about ten scripts that
I that I've written that I'd like just
really terrible but then the next one
it's gonna be good
why because how awesome would it be if I
had a daytime job writing television
here in New York and maybe stand-up at
night you know yeah that that's so
that's very comforting like 98 pages out
of a hundred are just nothing but you've
written 10 scripts is also incredible so
it's like you're working that writing
muscle and the more you write the more
opportunities you're giving yourself to
find that next great script or that next
great joke right and I think that I'm I
mean I just thought about this but when
you're a kid and you start playing Super
Mario or whatever the highest level of
difficulty is horrible and if you for a
beginner any of you thought oh oh well
I'm then why would I even try if there's
gonna take me a thousand hours to finish
but you're a kid and you have all the
time in your hands and and and you see
it as play as the thing that brings you
joy so you let yourself make mistake so
like that's I think that's the only
thing that prevents me over having
writer's block which I've never had is
to be like yeah
this is probably really awful oh but
what but buddy make me laugh so who
cares oh yeah I like your that's been
really helpful is just taking away the
pressure and expectation of creating
something funny it's almost just the the
act of writing is more important than
the result mmm ooh I like that quote the
act of writing is more important than
the result very quick Joe huh oh that's
a Joel ISM right there I'm acting like I
came up with I was like you pretty much
just guided me into thinking that but
that really does I think that's super
helpful for everyone to hear is it
really yeah just lower the bar it's a
law of averages just show up and write
write and write what is like we we
hinted at it but like going full-time
for you like what you thought about
quitting your job and moving in with
your girlfriend but then you didn't like
what is what that's that's about a
question a lot of comics have I didn't
because of the because of the apocalypse
is that it's happening okay so I'm like
lucky that I have my vision because I'm
still working from home getting paid so
I just love like this moment in the
world in Society of just how
nonchalantly you just said that
oh so what prevented you from going
full-time well I was going to but then
this apocalypse happened so we're just
gonna ride this out and see if the world
is I'll just keep getting paid to work
from home instead of not getting paid to
write another script yeah yeah that's
just yeah okay so so you're saying but
I'm sorry I completely forgot what you
were you asking oh I was just following
up on you had had the idea what's a lot
of comics right okay it's now time to go
full time comedy and I was wondering
what prevented you from taking that leap
right right so when I'm gonna get back
on track with that once we come back to
when I can go on the road
I do a few clubs in the road so then
that could give me that could bring me a
little bit of income and the factor that
made me think now is the time is the
fact that I have representation and they
go hey look there's all these doors that
are open if you bring the material so I
feel like every day that I because I'm
already writing 80 minutes a day right
but these days that I've been having off
I've been writing like I'm not writing
San that feels like I'm not training
with anybody so I'll just begin when we
can do stand-up again but I've been
writing at least two hours in the
morning and two hours at night oh my so
I'm doing like four hours of like script
writing cuz it's different it's less
complicated than stand-up it's it's I
mean it's more like you started writing
some stupid dialogue between two people
in your head and it's just like time
goes by so I figured okay I have the
opportunity I just need the time to like
grind for a year if I stay my day job
it's gonna take me and I work one hour a
day in the script it's gonna take me
five years to get good at it but with
the amount of work that I put in in a
day and I don't have a day job it's
gonna take me nine months right somebody
my idea for quitting a day job is look
there's somebody waiting for a really
good writing sample so I can get a stats
on a TV show or maybe the idea of
selling my own TV show so why not do
that Monday through Thursday worked like
a mule when it comes to that and then
Sunday through Thursday through Sunday
go feature somewhere and get better
stand-up and so there's no reason for me
to keep a day job even don't know making
the money I'm willing to make the
sacrifice of like of like having a way
low income because I'm building towards
something mm-hmm yes you have something
you're working towards which is super
helpful which also like me when I filmed
my special last year was having that to
work towards really motivated me
like okay even when you don't feel like
it show up to work anyway but if like
show up to the page get on stage things
like that and you time out lowering the
bar is helpful but like four hours dude
like what what are you doing on the days
you don't feel like writing how are you
convincing or tricking yourself into
doing it anyway mmm I mean so the good
thing about the day job is like I only
have that window right and you only have
like from 8:00 to like 9:00 from like
7:00 to 8:00 twenty so if it's for like
a person who loves exercise you didn't
work out that day they just feel guilty
then I just feel I feel bad the whole
day so for me it's not out it's it's
it's like it's it's for my own mental
health that I do it because otherwise
I'm gonna beat myself up oh we're not
doing that and now on the weekends it's
like okay I wake up and I get a lot a
cup of coffee and I watch The Simpsons
and then I sit down and I have like I
have an outline of okay I'm gonna write
a script about this stupid episode where
I think that and my sitcom there is a
guy who is working for the cartel but he
doesn't want to kill people
till he to him okay you have to go
interrogate this person but he doesn't
want to torture them so then he learns
he goes to a class and he learns
hypnosis and he comes back and tries to
like interrogate somebody who using
hypnosis and then somebody human attacks
the same and oh and sometimes [ __ ]
happens and and it's the end right I
have an outline so why don't you have
something that you're gonna like you
have twenty scenes and you and you've
spent ten minutes per scene that adds up
to like 200 minutes like your day goes
by like that so having having the
outline having the plan for a sitcom it
makes it easy to sit down right now how
do i trigger myself into writing I think
I just structure my day go watch The
Simpsons that's already a pleasurable
activity right then I sit down I and I
right for an hour and then I I take a
break and I have like some Nutella with
something right that's I'm rewarding
mess up again and then I write down for
another hour and then I I go on to ride
my bicycle for an hour and then I come
back and I write for another hour and
then I take a nap and then before my nap
is like it's a it's a different day my
brain is not fried and then I write a
little more it's just like it's just
creating it's creating at this point
until it becomes an Oni sure that you
didn't think about yeah that's that's
powerful I think yeah doing it piece by
piece but also having having that
structure and a reason to write I think
helps people whatever you create in your
head whatever that reason is that can
become like your motivator on days when
you're like yeah I'll get to it later or
whatnot but I feel the same way I have
to write in the morning otherwise I'm
just gonna like beat myself up over it
for the rest of the day right a lot of
us do so this this um
let's go ahead and land this plane here
real quick I have two more questions
Zee asked why did you decide to go
riding rather than acting most comedians
lean into acting I I suggest you watch a
clip of my stand-up to like see my range
of emotion but dude that that uh that
set it was killer thank you thank you no
but to give you like a more extends
answer is I'm also taking acting classes
okay so I'm just I'm doing everything
because I think I think we every I mean
everyone will tell you something
different Rea like what's his name
neighbor gat CSIS get 15 get get spend
fifteen years getting amazing and
stand-up and then somebody was gonna
come and give you a sitcom that's one
way of doing it another way of doing it
is like get good at everything gradually
so that when it's like something that I
would could I would tell myself if I
could go back for years I'd be like okay
dude you're not booked on Saturday and
you're not booking on Sunday
let's go to a read a book about how to
write a TV script take a take a class on
TV writing take an acting class so like
at least one day a week work on
something different if you like sketches
one day a week just write a sketch and
shoot a sketch on Sunday whatever
whatever it draws your attention is like
nortre different sides or like have a
podcast do one little thing that like
adds to your repertoire yes so that when
you get attention for your stand-up you
have an even bigger draw I'd be like
yeah I can act go audition and get a
sitcom work on some shitty sitcom that
you didn't even like but who cares money
and it brings you an audience now next
thing you know you can tour off your
role that you hate and your TV I love
that it's just having more than stand-up
and it sounds like I mean comedy isn't
your full-time job but you're already
treating it like it is which I think is
important for any comedian wanting to go
full-time start treating it like a job
now what are you waiting for even if you
have a day job you show up and give that
employer all your all and you treat
their business like a job treat your
business of stand-up like a job as well
right right so yeah it it's it's all
making sense for people listening only
six years six and half years in a comedy
already been on Colbert there's a reason
behind this opportunity you got and it's
because you're putting in the necessary
work for these things to happen so a lot
of comedians want that magic bullet but
I think what we've learned today is the
work is the magic bullet you're right so
this this is the final one here and this
is from Trent Babb he's out on the west
coast actually he tunes into the right
ten clubs every morning - so this is a
guy putting in the works because he's up
at 7:00 a.m. oh when wha 10:00 a.m. here
in Atlanta so 7:00 a.m. his time to join
the right ten club so he's a good job
yeah Trent's killin it
he had like two questions I think we can
kind of parlay into one here but let's
let's do this one first he's um are you
leaning more towards clean material
because it opens doors for you or do you
still tell dirty jokes at clubs I the
moment that I that I stopped doing that
the moment that I was done with Colbert
I think my brain was like okay now next
one I'm gonna sell to whoever I wanna I
wanna sell I don't want to do 15 late
nights because why nobody's giving you
sitcoms from doing a late night so then
I I'm allowing myself to be like okay
let's let me make this jokes dad like I
have this when last time I saw my
grandma she tried to sell me a blanket
like she gave me a blanket and then she
put a price on the blanket and that was
the last time that I spoke to my grandma
when she was alive so you and I'm trying
to I'm trying to like make a joke about
how much because she wanted to give me a
blanket in installments and so like so
like the the the joke that I haven't
figured out is like I should have taken
it because I wouldn't have to have to
pay for the [ __ ] blind kidding you'd
be a free blank the joke is never gonna
be in Lane ITV but there's something
about my life that I think it's it's it
sweet and I want to talk about it and
now I don't have the restriction of both
but but I see the things that I've never
been I've never worried about clean or
dirty because I haven't I've never
ridden for them I think I write for me I
think one mistake that people make is
because because crass jokes and
so-called edgy jokes it's just people
that make people groan and get a
reaction from people that's easier so I
think never use that as a crutch to be
like to just go and write that right how
many just every time that I watch is
said and it's about it if then it's a
dick joke or like something very like
it's really quick sexual and referent I
just go all right
anyone is doing those so write what you
want but just don't write for a reaction
write for because it makes you laugh and
it's funny yeah I think that's super
important is the big debate of clean
burst dirty is it's all personal
preference at the end of the day and
like you talked about when you write
it's your these are things like once you
were asked about what did you decide to
keep and things like that it's really
like what strikes you is funny
so if yeah if what's funny is clean to
you then by all means be clean you know
I I I consider myself a clean comedian
but that's only because it's what
organically that's where my sense of
humor organically goes you know and if
I'm an open mic or sometimes at a club I
mean I'll swear every now and then it's
not like all or nothing but it is my
personal sense of humor skews towards
clean and flipping things into the clean
perspective but that's me personally I
never tell a comic hey you don't do that
or you should be like this it's more
like what is your sense of humor and
just listen to it mm-hmm
yeah because there's there's enough
doors and opportunities for everyone now
and what people are looking for more
than ever now is authenticity and what
is true to you because comedies booming
and how you're going to stand out is by
creating comedy that's uniquely you and
no one else whether it's dirty or lean
what's gonna stand out is that
authenticity because people now more
than ever can sniff out when you're
putting on an act to get a certain like
I better be clean because I'll get XYZ
people people are gonna see through like
the the fake you know yeah but that is
that does tie in to and Trent says thank
you as well but this ties into the final
question as well as we're talking about
you and this has become one of my
favorite topics of discussion as I've
been talking about writing more and more
on here
is Trent asked do you ever feel trapped
writing just about you do the crowds
laugh from you material more than your
other bits so I guess if material is
more about you do they laugh more and do
you feel trapped by that I I feel
trapped
I don't feel trapped the only thing that
I don't like is like sometimes when I
tell my girlfriend a story or like a
friend and they're like that's so funny
go whatever you just told me go on say
that on the stage and and I go and then
people just look at me like so why
because I I don't know I so like you
know how you laugh and I was like
because of the apocalypse that happened
and then you laugh right I think that
when I deliver something like
organically as a story
it comes up very organically but then
when I could try to say in a sentence
like hey so you guys think this is funny
and then it just doesn't work so then it
works jokes work for me I I mean I'm we
talked about Colbert being very personal
but that just happened right I also have
jokes about things that I observed but
then also when you observe something the
most relatable way of presenting that is
to make up a little story were you part
of it hmm oh you know what I like I had
um I had this this joke where I'm
Michael Baer said about somebody telling
me to go back to my country right and
that happened I made it in convey in one
of those electrical the walkways for
simplicity because I was on an airplane
and there were other Latin passengers
getting out of the airplane to transfer
to our airplanes and there was a
Peruvian lady ahead of me and she was
trying to get out ahead of an American
person as a pilot had instructed I'm the
the American guy got man heater on he
said go back to your country as he was
blocking hurt from taking a plane to go
back to her country so I was like so
funny but why would I go and be like so
I was trying
to transfer planes and there was an old
lady and that so she's like no I'm gonna
take the place of the of the old lady
dude that is so fascinating so you're
you're how the story actually happened
was you second handedly saw this guy
tell a lady to go back to her country
but right sake of the joke you just made
yourself the old lady right Wow and
because people are not because I think
it's speaking about the difference
between personal comedy and observation
when I see a set and the person talks
for five minutes about the documentaries
that they've been watching on their
couch I just go like I don't know that I
want to heat I mean you would have it to
be Richard Pryor for me to for me to
listen to what you think is stupid on TV
right uh but there is always a way to
personalize comedy so that so that is
more digestible to people like I read
this article in The New York Times about
a woman who was talking about the
problems of dating while being in a
wheelchair and she was Catholic and she
said that she prayed every night
and she asked God to help her find love
and I thought of the Bible and I was
like in the Bible if you can't walk you
asked Jesus to like heal you right but I
can't just go and be like sounds reading
this article but this this stupid Bishop
wheelchair right who whose brain how
dumb are you it was like no like you can
think that right so then I just I wrote
a joke about I remember that used to
live in Philly and the Pope went to
Philly so I was like so I just made it
but so I just made the lady in the
wheelchair a male so I was not to like
be judgmental about her vulnerabilities
I'm dating and I I took him to the
parade to wave at the Pope and then he
waved the Pope and then he turns to me
he says I wish I could speak to the Pope
face-to-face so I could ask him to pray
that I find law and then I just said the
same thing that I tell with the lady I
was like that's not how it works
first Jesus accused the lab first Jesus
cures the leper and then they would
never find the girlfriend on his own
right and that was how the version that
I made that's okay and it's and it is
like me filtered yes you you put your
you almost filter the material through
Pedro and that's how you personalize
this you may see something but then you
just make it about you even if it wasn't
and then that's how you're able to
personalize material I think so and I
and I just think that it's not like a
conscious thing but like the more you
write comedy the more you realize that I
mean just look at the specials of like
really good like look at Sam rel a look
at Normand look at Michelle wolf as a
comedian just intend to look back and
they when they're like my friend told me
this and it's like that friend doesn't
exist mm-hmm your your presenting like a
philosophical like a little logical
argument and you're putting the the
person that you want to bring that the
opinion that you want to break down you
make it a human because the the
interaction between two people is what
creates the the be like oh and bury oh
that's that's funny
otherwise you'd be giving TED talks if
you're like I'm gonna dispute the fact
that I write but I thought I don't agree
with this Trump supporter and I love
that the more you write it's all mean
you know writing is like a muscle to and
it's like the more you write the more
aware you'll start to become of comedy
in your life because you're getting
better at it it's getting stronger your
sense of humor is getting more and more
in tuned so I think it is just the more
you create the more you right around
comedy just the more you'll start to see
it and the more you label you'll be able
to start filtering it through you and
onto like a personal set
stage right yeah and then this like on
the other spectrum there's some really
brilliant comedians who don't like you
would say okay
Andrew Scholes is observational because
he goes he has this bit about okay
women say this is the worst patriarchy
and then he goes on this thing about
like well some women in Africa have
their clitoris caught up and then he
just makes a case put in the worst case
scenario and just telling people in the
United States how they have a great and
then women are laughing at the fact that
he's saying that we have the best
patriarchy buh-buh-bah he's not in the
joke at all but you know what is his
point of view hmm and he's super strong
man that's a great point cuz I was
looking for it I was like yeah how does
he personalize it he personalize it with
his point of view that you say strong
point of view that he believes in so
then the audience will in turn trust and
believe in it also right
woo oh my gosh
yo Trevor just said this has been
awesome very insightful Thank You Joel
and Pedro this Trent says thank you this
I'm telling you kids holy cow
this has been a whirlwind and hopefully
the first of just many questions people
reach out to you about you know like
this this show like you know when you
when we connect on social media like
it's for comics by comics and you've
shared so much wave just even way more
than anticipated we had way more
questions than anticipated so hopefully
you know we'll be able to be doing more
of these Trent says fantastic
Alex says thank you as well so thank you
everyone for tuning into this Thank You
Pedro for being willing to do this and
share so much insight thank you so much
for having me yeah yeah and Z says
amazing thanks Pedro I'll keep an eye
for shows in Toronto so thank you yeah
that's great and Don says
great stuff thanks Joel and Pedro oh man
hey well we're changing lives out here
Pedro then what please let them know
where they can connect with you where
they can support you like please let
them know sure just follow me and Easter
gonna be like it's Pedro's jokes my name
the letter s and the word jokes perfect
all right and your website as well it's
Pedro Gonzalez comedy rock on Pedro
Gonzalez comedy calm and uh Z says we
have health care so the apocalypse
should end here first start booking your
Canadian tours guys good idea yeah
that's what's great about the hot breath
averse man we're all over the world so
it's it's cool that we can actually
start to come together in moments like
this and really interact and learn from
each other and a real in like intimate
way so I'm looking forward to more of
these thank you all for this idea I mean
this came up in the right 10th club on
regular Facebook live people were like
hey we'd like to ask questions the
people who have been on TV and I was
boom I know a guy we just connect on
social media Pedro Gonzales
so please hop Brett the verse reach out
to Pedro if you have any other questions
or just reach out just to say thank you
and for him sharing his valuable time
with us here today and keep supporting
hot breath by the best way to do it is
by just sharing it with other comedians
on social media in your favorite comedy
Facebook groups you can support the show
with our patreon if you go to
patreon.com/scishow pod if you want to
add a little bit to our patreon tip jar
there but overall just keep sharing this
keep connecting in these times I hope
you're staying safe out there and
staying smart out there and join this
Facebook group if you're not a member we
have a very special announcement that we
will do right now that we teased earlier
in the write 10 club but tomorrow as of
2:00 p.m. tomorrow 2:00 p.m. eastern
time we're having Sean Patton come on
the show so if you guys haven't heard
his
episode on hot breath it's episode 184
but he has one of our most like highly
complimented and highly educational
episodes about writing and storytelling
so he's gonna be on here tomorrow at 2
p.m. so definitely tell your other
comedian friends and family that that's
gonna be back here he'll be back here
tomorrow with us live but Pedro you
started something here buddy you started
something we're I'm so glad that this
new series hot breath live started with
you and I wish you all the luck and
continued success and the work your work
ethic man has just it's it's it's really
inspiring and I think my big takeaways
from this are one just show up and do
the work you know writing a hundred
pages and 98 or terrible but those two
pages are the gold you know and just
just showing up lowering the bar not
having any expectations beyond just
starting that's my big takeaway from
this just start take away all
expectations just allow yourself to just
show up and create without any
expectation cuz you don't have you you
never have a map for like imagine did
you did you know that your podcast was
gonna turn into this this is great
you've interviewed Stokes great
comedians and you're like given so much
information how to become a better
comedian to a lot of people and you
didn't know at the start that he was
gonna get so good no it's just started
who that's what so that yet thank you
also
Wow Thank You Pedro Manuel I'm excited
to do more things together this has been
great and absolutely ha kids out there
the the group is called hot breath
Comedy Network it'll be linked in the
show notes but Pedro Gonzalez thanks for
being on hot breath my man thank you and
we will see everyone else
next Monday right here on hot
all right kids keep grinding out there
stay safe and smart and we love you